[Music]
uh
shan hello uh do what are some ways
guys and girls uh flirt differently
oh okay i'm trying to think about like
the answer that because
i guess women's iois like indicators of
interest
would be um like subconsciously touching
themselves
sitting in an s formation what's an s
formation like this
there you go i find myself doing this a
lot wait this is more of a nest
okay that's weight this is how they
should do it
yeah dude i got these guys bothered yeah
like you're a [ __ ] falcon
okay okay oh yeah that's it what does
this signal like is it more like
well it just emphasizes curves oh [ __ ]
they subconsciously
yeah so they don't even know that
they're doing it you might not
but you can turn it on but i think that
when people are attracted to somebody
yeah
i've noticed i noticed this the the yeah
yeah
i noticed a lot of the finger [ __ ] in
the mouth a little bit
yes you don't i don't know what's that
you gotta say gotta say i noticed that
[Laughter]
i was yeah water at the perfect time you
son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
is this something that they do
subconsciously or they're doing it
because they feel a certain way
it's subconscious but you can obviously
purposefully do it if you understand
these
and then you can actually get people to
like you and they won't know why like
mirroring is a huge one
and that's uh across all genders so like
oh [ __ ] oh like oh i feel connected
[ __ ] your mouth oh she's
cool see you liked her now see it works
that's how it's done
she got me here and it worked it worked
she asked to see my dick last video
maybe i'll show her now
you said it was serrated i've never
heard that described before
now we all got to see him that's what
we're all dealing with you called her
charlie brown dick now immediately
charlie brown got the t-shirt i'm a huge
fan i love it i want to see it charlie
bryant it's not scary it's more like
it's got like a caribbean tip
like a sword bro these terms
i got is not like a rapier thank you
okay i got one of those there it is
boom see that wow that's like steve's
dick but it's like a dick
really no struggling there joe steve's
dick has a gold tip you really
should just stick with caribbean dick
thank you i will next time
that's there you've got something there
i had you and i lost you
all right oh so what what are some ways
the guys uh
flirt uh trying to appear more square
just like squaring
the exact opposite of what women do i
guess yeah
like this voices will deepen yeah what's
up baby boys get a little bit deeper
hey what's up hey baby what's up baby oh
[ __ ] what a sword
baby this might work out dudes too man
this might work
hey baby pelvis aligned to the person
that they're
squaring up attracted to person like
that kind of well he's got square up to
you too
oh [ __ ] what's up a lot of thigh
touching huh yeah pelvis pelvis
i don't even know that yeah so there's a
whole study
of how people flirt like there's actual
scientists that are psycho psychologists
that study how people flirt and the
latest in this field
of research is that they're studying the
tactics in which
uh women competitively flirt
against other women oh i like that and
that's something that
a lot of these professors are saying oh
yeah we've never actually looked into
that
women competitively flirt yeah so one
guy hold on can you predict this
okay can you predict what they might do
no okay
i've never even heard of this before
nice yeah right even a lot of the
people partaking they're like yeah how
come no one's you know researched this
or even looked into like the mannerisms
they just watched the bachelor so is it
the swooping
it's swooping yeah or like say like you
had a party there's a guy and then
two girls you know walk up to the guy
and they're like oh
oh you're putting a move i wanted to put
it and then they're basically at the
same time putting the moves
on the guy and basically there's certain
things that they would do
to deter and say hey he's mine back the
[ __ ] off
has that happened to you before no i'm
just like who's the guy that gets this
yeah yeah bart you know when you're on
the cart yeah especially when my
baby around yeah that's not that's
probably fact but that's
not like all of a sudden when dudes have
a kid
now they're that much more desirable to
everyone yes yeah yes
why do it happen when it's like when
you're more off limits they want you
like you have a kid and a family and you
have a wife and then now they want to
[ __ ] you harder
where were you when i was single there's
twofold reasons for this
one it's because when you don't when the
stakes are low for you you exude more
confidence
so so guys have that chill energy it's
like that's like that's seductive right
like i'm speaking to you i really don't
care if you like me or not and i'm just
like but like me
you know and then the second thing is
that because they're signifying to other
partners that they
are the kind of candidates who would
stay with somebody so like he said like
i want him
and they could provide right provider
because he's raising a child
so there's nothing more sexier than and
he's got fertile loins
the full package it's very important
these days strong
travel tats will do it travel tasks gets
chicks wet i know that for a fun
yeah dude i gotta get some tribal tats
just for me though just for me though
i'm gonna have a busload of kids then
how about that bus
all right so shannon so what are some
ways say you know just
rewind the clocks and uh you're single
uh and you see a guy and you walk up to
the guy and you wanna
you know basically and his name is casey
you know
like you know why back the club
not casey uh yeah it's just some guy all
right and then another woman walks up
all right yeah what are what are some of
the tactics you would do
to deter the other woman and be like hey
back the [ __ ] off i'm talking to him
um i'd probably try to act like i knew
more about him so it's like to establish
that our rapport is greater
so the person would feel awkward to be
there i've seen that
really that's good i've seen that but
it's usually like friendship wise
like not necessarily relationship things
but like i've seen it between girls
before where they're like
oh we go back to here and then the other
goes like we go back to here and like
it's like an interesting thing but it's
almost like a cl like a classic
bridesmaid scene right
yes where where she was like oh but i
remember in second grade you really
wanted to go here for the summer and the
other lady like no no she likes paris
now
yeah so no no we want to go to that lake
whatever place how do guys do it
he likes corvettes no no no he doesn't
he likes trucks
no just say he likes corvettes and then
the chicks like oh
i mean like guys within each other all
right yeah yeah so like how would guys
do it
um i was his best friend first that's
what it really is right not that though
it's more just like
i would be so if we're all in a group
then i would be like
bart like didn't taika just do a
somersault for the first time yesterday
and then you're like oh yeah he did you
want to see the video yeah and then like
now i'm shoulder to shoulder videoing it
up
and then this person's like what i want
to see
yeah the person could play that but then
they're kind of like this
loser
all right so some of the most uh common
ways to
to non-verbally flirt when there's
another
uh like rival woman around uh
is to make more eye contact than them
uh constantly dancing in the line of his
sight
that works always smiling more than your
competition
in all scenarios dancing in the light of
this sight every time
and smiling the whole time it doesn't
matter the context you dance
you're a [ __ ] ass off if you're out
of trophies dance
and then one of the more egregious ones
is budding in between
the other woman and the man like
literally placing your body in between
like shielding off the dogs do that all
the time yeah
you pet one and the other one gets
jealous and they come right in between
hell
it's the cutest thing and then sometimes
they start raping each other
i go you don't deserve it and i push
them and then i go
and they get really jealous
but yeah and then a lot of glaring eye
rolls and frowning were also
uh found in this research so they
basically found
91 women and they uh basically asked
them like in this situation and they had
a multiple
choice uh answer and so they basically
checked off what they think they would
do in this situation and it came back
that
shielding themselves away from the other
woman and literally glaring
eye rolls and frowning were one of the
number one
like tactics that they would do so it's
pretty like i don't know like
primal yeah like it's not even like i
thought it'd be like more
like incognito and like like very very
like smooth
smooth operators you know and not really
tricks get it done though bro well
primo's
like when you watch because when this
happens in the wild you fight until
somebody dies
right if there's two of you who are
trying to court one so i think this is
the opposite of primal something quite
sophisticated it's quite sophisticated
have you seen the videos of monkeys
where they
they will kill and eat each other but
they don't even want to eat the
other monkeys they just [ __ ] eat each
other to prove dominance yeah polar
bears will fight to the death
it's crazy over a lady yeah like
straight up until one is dead
and sometimes both die because they ran
out of energy or they
like like the win like the winner the
winner killed the other one
but because it hadn't ate like a seal
for days it ran out of energy and that
guy just passes out too damn you should
just ate polar bear just for one night
and right rams during mating season they
the bucks come and they
bam they get cte oh my god
right yeah but then they don't kill it
they're just like okay you lost get the
[ __ ] out of here
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] outta
here dude it's my lady now
they get brain damage probably
and it's harder to find a mate going
forward i know they're too stupid
they're like i don't like this stupid
guy
this stupid guy he can't even speak i
got brain damage dude
you look good on the day with me
that's crazy but yeah so this uh
research has also now opened up this
question of how the lgbtq community also
conduct themselves so like they're
basically going into different
uh uh demographics to kind of isolate
them and see
how they intro there's a word intra
intro interact interact or intra
sexually
compete with each other yeah that's
pretty interesting i mean
is it that much of a surprise though
because it seems pretty
like duh that people compete for who
they want
right it doesn't it's not gender
specific but the execution's just
different yeah
and people are people who are maybe less
experienced are seeking out that
knowledge because they're like how do i
do it i don't know how to do it and
stuff like this helps
inform that yeah but what's effective is
the question right
is that what they're trying to figure
out like yeah they didn't make a point
they're saying this is the perceived uh
effectiveness rather than the actual
effectiveness yeah so because they then
actually put these people in a scenario
where they're
vying for a person's affections right
they're just doing like a
a survey because there's so much that
comes into play right for someone to
what's happening in that scenario who
the person is that they want to be the
biggest variable
is the guy's likes and dislike yeah
i'm just glad they're doing this not
like guys looking at craig ferguson
videos where he's talking to actresses
and then
they do microphone uh voiceovers and
like this is how craig is
seducing alice eve
she is he is working her with this
technique he's nagging her a little bit
now she's like oh i'm lesser than craig
ferguson
and then he takes a drink from his snake
cup implying he has a big
large [ __ ] and i'm like dude how are
these videos
on youtube they're all cucks bro dude
how do you find
a video i don't know send you guys my
playlist dude it's [ __ ] incredible
there pickup artist dudes out there
they're the worst brothers they're the
worst
and they're trying to teach dudes like
using dudes in media who are talking to
chicks
and they're going here's what he's
secretly doing and they'll take me right
oh they always do it for the guy who are
from mad men
yeah yes john hamm yeah they do it from
him they do it for russell brand
and they have russell brand talking to
some hot chick and then muscle brands
was like
hey let go of the mate like oh
you're like oh see what he's doing there
he's just throwing it all away he's like
he's making her laugh and it's getting
her [ __ ] wet and all this [ __ ]
i learned a lot from those videos do you
i do i learn about
you learn how delusional people are no
you learn little tips i actually look
what did i watch when i watch one on
john hamm for something oh
how to exude like ultimate confidence
and
he says that after you finish saying
something boss don't fidget
so i notice i do that like if i'm in an
interview and i'm like i just killed
that [ __ ] i'll be like ring ring
i'll just like fidget my ring or
something or if i just finished speaking
in general and it was like
if you just stay still in those moments
so but what if you're constantly fidgety
though does that negate because then
like if you got adhd
you just kind of like you just say
something profound and you're just doing
this the whole time
you're like yo that guy's a genius bro
he has a nervous tic he's a genius
dad that guy's [ __ ] confident right
there dude watch those videos they're
good
i can only do it if i actually am
confident about it otherwise i can't
stick the landing and i just i sell it
out
i haven't seen it once so far thank you
i wasn't even sure the last
monologue was going and i felt that you
felt that i didn't know
and you still kept going with it i
didn't know where it was going either
[Music]
you